this morning school sign is supposed to
read sewage plant field trips are today
so can either of you explain why it now
reads come see my hairy armpits I know
you two are responsible how how do you
know do you have any proof ever since
you've attended this elementary school
you've been responsible for one prank
after another
[Music]
wow that's a lot of pranks yeah when
it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope some of
those must've been really hard to pull
off and dangerous like that tiger oh
that tank it was crazy ah what is
happening right now I don't know let's
try and leave and see what happens Wow
what's an expensive door mm-hmm from the
studio that brought you Shrek Kung Fu
Panda and Madagascar hi I'm Jorge beer
miss my best friend Harold Hutchins we
just make comics and try to make each
other laugh and this old guy is mr. Kruk
George
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you've attended this school
you've been responsible for one prank
after another
some of those must've been really hard
to pull off like that tiger or that tank
it was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you to place its
separate glasses we're going to
annihilate the friendship huh don't you
do something
put the ping down mr. crup or will
hypnotize you my fingers you will obey
our every command Rolo I don't even
think that what happened this summer
come sidekick we gotta stop him
why thank you vehicle person oh yeah
who's robbing go get him their greatest
creation Captain Underpants you can't
actually fly I take to the sky like an
Oscar wow he is super dumb he's now
their biggest problem Staggs ow you
monster
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon
hi you're Claire I'm your new teacher
not some scary guy with a secret evil
agenda guys I totally got this now
totally he's got it Kevin Hart Ed Helms
Thomas Middleditch Nick Kroll when it's
cut all together like that you really
get a sense of the scope DreamWorks
Captain Underpants pour so you're
trapped in some sort of invisible box
like prison is it okay that I'm kind of
loving this
yep enough I will set you free oh but
mostly yet
[Music]